مساؤكم واهلا بكم الى التاسعه هذا المساء
وهذه عناوينها
عشيه الاحتفال بعيد النصر موسكو تكثف
غارات على كيف والنيت يرفع حاله التاهب
عوده قويه للشبكات في الخرطوم واندرمان
وحرب السيطره على الجسور مستمره
باسم الشعب والامه حملات المرشحين لرئاسه
التركيه تحاول استقطاب الاتراك بشعارات
وطنيه
بالنسبه لقضيه المخدرات كما اكدنا سابقا
هو هي تهديد كبير
للمملكه وللمنطقه وللعالم مصادر
استخباراتيه تؤكدس الاردن استهدف موقعين
المخدرات بجنوب سوريا وقتل المطلوب الاول
[موسيقى]
وفي تفاصيل التاسعه هذا المساء لا تمنع
اجواء الحرب والتهديدات الامنيه موسكو من
الاستعداد الاحتفال بيوم النصر على
النازيه
عازم على اقامه الاحتفالات التقليديه في
الميدان الاحمر وسط اجراءات امنيه مشدده
لكن موسكو الغت الاحتفالات في سته اقاليم
تقع ضمن 400 ميل من الحدود الروسيه
الاوكرانيه خوفا من تكرار هجمات وقعت
اخيرا بمسيارات داخل البلاد بالاضافه
لاستهداف كريم لان
[موسيقى]
اذا عصر جديد من الحرب افتتحته كييف
فالمسرح بات مهيئا لجيلا جديد القدرات
العسكريه محوره الذكاء الاصطناعي ودرون
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه شرعت الابواب
لتطوير هذا السلاح وزادها تقدما وحنكه ان
صح التعبير الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي فتح
المجال لسوق كبير وفعال في ذات الوقت
بالمجال العسكري وفق محللين عسكريين هذه
المسيرات لا تقدر بثمن لا سيما في خطوط
المواجهه الاماميه فهي صغيره رخيصه يمكن
ان تقدم بثا مباشرا لمواقع العدو وبشكل
دقيق الطائرات المسيره وان كانت بطيئه
وعرضه لنيران الاسلحه الصغيره يمكن
استخدامها ضمن اسراب لارباك الدفاعات
الجويه وبعضها قد يخترقها ايضا وهنا
بالمقارنه مع الصواريخ فالاخيره تطير
بسرعه عاليه ويصعب اسقاطها لكنها تكلف
مئات الالاف او ملايين الدولارات وفي وقت
استخدمت روسيا المسيرات لقصف الم
الاوكرانيه وايضا البنيه التحتيه الحيويه
اعتمدتها اوكرانيا بكثافه لضرب المراكز
اللوجيه الروسيه ووفرت لها ميزه التقدم
بالحرب علما بان سوق الدرون ضل محصورا
بتسليم الطرود المحليه وربما عروض الاضاءه
حتى اندلاع الحرب الاوكرانيه التي اظهرت
امكانياتها الهائله
[موسيقى]
المسيرات التي كثفت خروجها واستهدافاتها
وافشلت سيطره الروس على السماء اوكرانيا
لقيت رديفها الروسي فرد الروسي على
المسيرات الاوكرانيه حلقت به قنابل مجنحه
جديده تعرف بالقنابل الانزلاقيه لتعويضات
صواريخ كروز هذا السلاح الروسي الاحدث
الذي تجاربه موسكو قد يغير مسار الحرب
ويجبر كييف على اعاده كتابه خطتها
العملياتيه للهجوم المضاد وذلك وفقا
لصحيفه ديل تيليجراف القنابل الانزلاقيه
او قنابل التخطيط اذا هي قنابل جويه مجنحه
وارخص واسهل في الانتاج من الصواريخ
البالسيه وحتى صواريخ كروز تم تزويدها
باجنحه كما تشاهدون وتمنحها نطاقا اضافيا
ومرونه للتحليق على ارتفاعات منخفضه وحتى
بعيده كما ان حجمها الصغير يصعب امكانيه
رصها بواسطه وسائل الدفاع الجوي التقليديه
وبالتالي تجنب مخاطر الطلعات قرب الخطوط
الاماميه في هذه النوعيه من القنابل
التكتيكيه هي مجهزه بانظمه التوجيه
والملاحه بالقصور الذاتي وحتى الاقمار
الصناعيه ما يسمح لها بتحديد مصارحلتها
تجاه الاهداف مباشره مسؤلون اوكرانيون
كانؤكدوا ان الجيش الروسي يطلق ما لا يقل
عن 20 قنبله زلابيه يوميا ووصفوها
بالتهديد الخطير للغايه
[موسيقى]
اكد مسؤولون امريكيون واوروبيون ان هجوم
الربيع المضاد المخطط لاوكرانيا يمكن ان
يمهد طريق المفاوضات بين كييف وموسكو
بحلول نهايه العام وفق ما نقلته صحيفه
وولد لافتين الى نصين يمكن ان تساعد في
جلب روسيا الى طاوله المفاوضات ويمثل
الاستعداد لتشجيع المفاوضات والسعي لدور
الصين في المحادثات تحولا في التفكير
الغربي
تشكك بقدره الصين على مساعده بنزع فتيل
الصراع لكن هذا النهج يستند وفق المسؤولين
انفسهم لاعتقاد سائدا بعدم قدره اي من
الجانبين على مواصله القتال الى اجل غير
مسمى
على كل حال نذهب مباشره الى موسكو معنا من
هناك مراسل عربيه عبد الجواد الرشد والى
كيف مراسل عربيه ايضا حذيفه عادل اهلا
بكما معنا في التاسعه هذا المساء عبد
الجواد ابدا معك اولا تشديد الامني بعد
المسيرات على هل في تغيير في الخطه
المدروسه روسيا بعد هذا الاستهداف خصوصا
في احتفالات يوم النصر يوم غد
مساء الخير نادين لك ولي حذيفه نعم يعني
حتى هذه اللحظه يتحدث عن عدم وجود اي
تغيير في خطته او في السيناريو المتبع
لاحتفال عيد النصر او طبعا العرض على
العسكري الذي سيرافق هذا طبعا يعني عيد
النصر كما جرت العدو ويجري في معظم المدن
الروسيه وفي الاقاليم لكن في نسخه هذه
العام وطبعا للوضع الامني تم تقليل سعيد
الناصري يعني على سبيل المثال المنطقه
الجنوبيه طبعا تم الاعتماد على اقامه
العرض العسكري والاحتفال الكبير فقط في
مدينه رستوف على نهر الدوم لذلك طبعا هو
الوضع غير مستقر هناك قلق اشاره هناك ضغوط
امنيه تواجد كبير لعناصر الامن
واليات العسكريه في العديد من المكان
وخاصه في مركز المدينه في نقطه اخيره بما
يخص الوضع
سماعات البلوتوث جميع الامور المرتبطه
بهذا الوضع هناك تشويش عليها لا يعمل نظام
الجي بي اس الخرائط في المدينه نوعا ما
طبعا للحفاظ على الوضع هذا اذا في الجانب
الروسي والاستعدادات ماذا عن الجانب
الاوكراني حذيفه اليوم هل من تخوف قلق
تحذير من هجوم روسي محتمل ليلوح في الافق
وفق التقارير الاوكرانيه في يوم النصر
مساء الخير نادين لك ولزميل عبد الجواد
صحيح ما تقولين هنالك قلق كبير جدا ومخاوف
وسط الاوكرانيين من ان يكون هنالك استهداف
كبير في هذه الليله اتوقع ان تبيت الاسر
الاوكرانيه اليوم بحذر شديد وان تراقب
السماء بشكل كبير جدا خاصه ان في الليله
الماضيه كان هنالك استهداف للعاصمه في
جميع تقريبا مناطق كيف يعني لا يوجد حي في
كيف لم يطير من فوقه بالامس في الليله
الماضيه طائره مسيره او تم اسقاط طائره
مسيره في المنطقه لذلك هنالك قلق كبير
كذلك السلطات قلقه من هذه الليله من ان
يكون هنالك هجوم كبير من قوى من قبل
الاتحاد الروسي ولكنها ايضا تقول انها
جاهزه لاي هجوم نحو العاصمه كيف او نحو
الاراضي طبعا
هذه الصور الان وسنعرضها لكم لاستهدافات
ليله امس وصلتنا الان نتابع معكم هذه
الاستهدافات
وطبعا المعارك على اشدها في الفتره
الاخيره ولكن نستمع لصوت الطبيعي ومن ثم
نعود اليكم
[موسيقى]
اعود اليك حذيفه لتكمل فكرتك
طيب
يبدو ان حذيفه لا يسمعني على كل حال ساعود
الى عبد الجواد الان عبد الجواد على ذكر
النصر ويوم النصر وفق التقارير الروسيه
وما يلوح في الافق روسيا انطلاقا لسير
المعارك وتطورات الميدانيه على الارض هل
من
مصر يلوح في الافق في يوم النصر
نادين سابدا من الخبر العاجل حيث ان يعني
الذخائر اصبحت تصله من وزاره الدفاع وهو
طاب قوسين او ادنى من السيطره على باتمان
في الحقيقه ناديني يعني
الداخل الروسي يؤمن بنصر موس ولكن طبعا
على العقلاء بين موسكو وكيف يرون بان
الرابع في هذه المعركه هو خاسر بالفعل
يعني
قسمت الشعب الواحد الى نسرين هي طبعا اله
السياسي لعبت في موس لعبت بالمنطقه لدى
موسكو طبعا كانت هناك مخاوف كثيره لم يتم
الاتفاق بما يخص القضايا الامنيه مع الغرب
وهذا ما ادى الى الصراع لذلك طبعا نادين
كل يعني كل الخيارات هي متاحه لكن في
الداخل الروسي يؤمنون بالنصر طبعا وتحقيق
النصر بما يخص السيطره وابعاد
وليس النصر على الشعب الاوكراني مشاهدينا
نشير هذا الخبر عجل كما اشار عبد الجواد
رشد قبل قليل قائد فاجنر بريجوجن سلمنا
الذخيره وبدايه قتال عنيف في ضخمه وكان
هذا الفيديو الذي اثار جدلا واسعا والذي
نشره بيغوشن شخصيا تم نشره وهو يوجه رسائل
شديده اللهجه ويتحدث فيها عن مفاد الذخيره
طيب على كل حال نذهب الى حذيفه مره اخرى
حذيفه اليوم عندما تحدثنا عن وتتحدث كيف
انها تتعرض لاكبر هجوم منذ بدايه الحرب ما
اخر المستجدات حتى اللحظه
صحيح طبعا بالاضافه للهجوم الذي تم في
الليله الماضيه ايضا تعرضت الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لاحدى عشر ضربه صاروخيه في
مناطق متفرقه من البلاد من ضمنها منطقه في
ضواحي العاصمه اكيد بالاضافه الى بعض
المدن القريبه من القتال
اوديسانيكا كذلك منطقه التي تعرضت لضربات
الصواريخ كان هنالك 61
ضربه
غاره جويه واكثر من 50 ضربه براجمات
الصواريخ القتال في اشده طبعا في محور
مخموت مارينكا
زاره طبعا قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
جبهه باق بشكل عام
واجتمع بالقيادات العسكريه في المنطقه
وقال ان الاجتماع بشكل مباشر في موقع
القتال جعلهم يستطيعون ان يحلوا كثير من
المشاكل التي لا يمكن حلها عن بعد لذلك
كانت هذه الزياره هامه جدا خاصه في عمليات
الامداد وايصال الذقائر طبعا القوات
الاوكرانيه تص ير على التمسك بجبهه ضخمه
ولان هذه الجبهه بالنسبه لهم تمثل ممسك
للقوات الروسيه من توسيع نطاق الجبهه اكثر
من ذلك شكرا جزيلا لكما من كيف حذيفه عدل
ومن موسكو عبد الجواد الرشد
[موسيقى]
لا شيء اتغير لكن حسابات الناس تغيرت
فالبيت يبقى هو البيت الحرب هنا ولا يوجد
مكان امن في اوكرانيا لكن اكثر من خمسه
ملايين ونصف مليون لاجئ عادوا الى ديارهم
بعد تجديد منازلهم وفق صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز النازحون العائدون ليسوا فقط من
سكان مدن كبرى مثل كييف ودانيبرو بل بعضهم
يقطن مناطقه تبعد 48 كيلومترا فقط من خط
المواجهه مثل بوبيروسك هؤلاء عادوا بعد
عام او اكثر على الفرار لتعج اسواقهم
بالباعه والمره وتملا اصوات اطفالهم
الشوارع وان لم تطهو على صوت الرصاص
مقداره الخطر الذين هم على استعداد لقبوله
غير معروف والتكيف مع الحرب ضبابيه كما
دخان القذائف التي ينامون على صوتها يوميا
لكنهم اتفقوا جميعا على المرونه
[موسيقى]
التاسعه هذا المساء مستمر ونتابع في
سياقها ولكن بعد قليل
تقفي الابوابها بوجه الهاربين من الصراع
في السودان
[موسيقى]
يستمرون معكم في التاسعه هذا المساء وفيها
قال رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان قال ان الجيش السوداني
اقترب من انهاء وجود الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم عبر البرهان في تصريحات ادلى بها
للاعلام المصري عبر عن شكره للسعوديه على
استضافتها للمفاوضات الهادفه لوقف القتال
في السودان كما اعرب البرهان عن خشيه
القوات المسلحه من انتقال الحرب الى
ولايات السودان الاخرى مشيرا الى استحاله
الحديث عن اي موعد لوقف اطلاق نار حاليا
خاصه في ظل تمركز قوات دعم السريع في
الاحياء السكنيه مشددا في الوقت ذاته على
ان الحل السلمي هو الطريق الامثل لحل
الازمه الحاليه في السودان
24 يوما مروا على اندلاع الاشتباكات في
السودان هدى شكليه وجهود سياسيه لحل
الازمه اخرها محادثات جدا والتي تستمر
لليوم الثالث بين طرفين زاع برعايه سعوديه
امريكيه التي تهدف لوضع حدا للمواجهات
وايجاد خطط لوقف النار
[موسيقى]
اسبوع رابع ينتصف من مواجهه السودان الذي
يمضي في طريق العوده نحو 500 مدنيين على
الاقل ذهبوا ضحيه النزاع المسلح فضلا عن
الاف المصابين واعداد اكبر للنازحين هنا
في جده تستمر المحادثات التمهيديه بين
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوه الدعم
السريع برعايه سعوديه امريكيه الخارجيه
السعوديه اكدت ان طرفي النزاع اعرب عن
تحملهما مسؤوليه وصول المساعده الانسانيه
العاجله واستعاده الخدمات الضروريه في
السودان كما شرع الطرفان في مراجعه اعلان
الالتزام بحمايه المدنيين وتيسير واحترام
العمل الانساني
وتسعى محادثات جده الى وضع جدول زمني
لمفاوضات موسعه للوصول لوقف دائم للاعمال
القتاليه كما دعت الرياض وواشنطن طرفي
النزاع في السودان الى احترام وقف اطلاق
النار الق حاليا والامتناع عن القيام باي
افعال استفزازيه تؤثر على سير المحادثات
محادثات في جده واجتماع عربي طارئ في
القاهره نتج عنه انشاء لجنه اتصال عربيه
لوقف النار في السودان تتكون من وزير
الخارجيه السعودي ونظره المصري والامين
العام للجامعه العربيه
جهود سياسيه للتهدئه تقابلها تحركات
انسانيه وحملات اجلاء مستمره تبنتها
السعوديه اخرها تقديم مساعدات انسانيه
متنوعه بقيمه 100 مليون دولار واطلاق حمله
شعبيه
لمسانده الشعب السوداني
ليس هناك جسر حليف في السودان غائب عن
ساحه المعركه او لا يلعب دورا محوريا فيها
فهي ممرات امداد تموينيه وايضا لدعم قوات
الطرفين بالعناصر والمعدات لكن ما اهم هذه
الجسور ومن يسيطر عليها البدايه من جسر
النيل الابيض هو يربط الخرطوم بام درمان
السيطره عليه تعني السيطره على اكثر مراكز
الدوله حيويه وهو الان بيد الجيش فالجسر
يقود الى شارع النيل الذي بدوره يؤدي الى
القصر الجمهوري وايضا المقر الحكوميه مثل
مجلس الوزراء وزاره الداخليه والخارجيه
والمعادن والطاقه جسر اخر يربط الخرطوم
باندرمان كما نشاهده هو بقبضه الجيش يطل
من ناحيه ام درمان على مواقع عسكريه بينها
كليه القياده والاركان وقياده لواء
المدفعيه الراجمات اهميه السيطره عليه
تتمثل بالتحكم بمعظم حركه السير هذه
الحركه القادمه من جنوب الخرطوم عبر شارع
الغابه تقييد حركه المدنيين ميزه يتمتع
بها كذلك جسر المكنمر الذي يربط الخرطوم
ببحر ويمثل ايضا شريان خيالي المدينتين
وهو بيد قوات الدعم السريع الى شريان
المعركه الرئيسي والمتمثل بجسر النيل
الازرق الذي يربط بين الخرطوم وبحري وهو
الان تحت سيطره الجيش يعد اخطر الجسور في
هذه المرحله لانه اقرب الطرق للقياده
العامه وتقع على طريقه اهم الوحدات
العسكريه والحكوميه بينها مقر قوه دعم
السريع وقصر الضيافه ورئاسه جهاز
المخابرات نذهب معكم الى جسر كوبر هذا
الجسر الذي تسيطر عليه القوات المسلحه هو
يربط بين الخرطوم وبحري ويشرف مباشره على
ناحيه الخرطوم على الاتجاه الشمال الشرقي
من مطار الخرطوم الدولي والقياده العامه
نذهب الان الى جسر الحلفايه هذا الجسر
الذي يربط اندرمان ببحري وهو يمثل قاعده
استراتيجيه منفصله واهم جسر في المعركه
الحاليه هو هدف للقوات الدعم السريع
وتحميه القوات المسلحه بشكل كبير
[موسيقى]
بتاع
نذهب الى الخرطوم على هناك الصحه في عمار
ابو شيبه اهلا بك عمار معنا في التاسع هذا
المساء حتى نفهم الصوره اليوم ونقرب الوضع
اكثر هل من يتحكم في الجسور الان يتحكم في
المعركه
اهلا بك واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام في كل
مكان نعم من يتحكم في الجسور يستطيع وبشكل
كبير جدا ان يتحكم في ربما عدد كبير جدا
مما مرات المناطق والشوارع وحتى الاحيان
باعتبار ان المعارك تدور داخل هذه الاحياء
وتدور داخل مناطق حساسه واستراتيجيه بشكل
واضح فمثلا جسر القوات المسلحه الشهير
والمعروف باسم جسر كوبر هذا الجسر يقود من
منطقه تدور فيها اشتباكات مباشره وكبير
جدا منطقه الصناعيه بحري ومنطقه كافوري
وينقل هذا الجسر من شمال مدينه بحري الى
المنطقه الشرقيه في مدينه الخرطوم وايضا
يربط ما بين القياده العامه وجزء من مطار
الخرطوم او جزء من المطار العسكري يربط
ايضا كذلك بحي بري وهنالك اشتباكات تدور
نعمار مثلا انت والمواطنون كيف تعبرون هذه
الجسور هل تتعرضون لعمليات تفتيش مثلا
تدقيق ماذا
نعم يعني كثير جدا من الحالات وحتى
مشاهدات ارضيه من خلال تنقلنا ما بين
منطقه واخرى محاوله التنقل يمكن ان نقل من
خلال هذه المشاهدات يعني مررنا بعدد من
الارتكازات في لحظات كنا نلتقي بارتكازات
وتفتيش من قبل قوات الدعم السريع وفي
لحظات اخرى نلتقي بتفتيش وارتكازات من قبل
الجيش السوداني عدد من الجسور احيانا تكون
خاليه من الجانبين واحيانا يتواجد فيها
قوات مثلا للدعم السريع او للجيش هي حرب
كروه فر قد تسيطر عليها خاصه عدد من
الجسور كجسر مناطق مناطق بحري منطقه
الحلفايه من جانب ام درمان تتواجد فيه
القوات المسلحه ومن جانب مدينه بحري
احيانا تتواجد فيه قوات الدعم السريع
وكثيرا ما كنا نشاهد فيه ايضا تواجد له
القوات الدعم السريع تبدو هذه المناطق هي
المناطق ذاتها شاشه في التحكم وحتى
السيطره لكي استوضح
جسر شمبات التاريخي القديم المعروف الذي
يربط ما بين مدينه بحري ومدينه ام درمان
القديمه بحر القديمه
الشهير بجواره معسكر المظلات او الدائره
الطبيه للقوات الدعم السريع ومن جانب ام
درمان هذا الجسر يربط مع البلده القديمه
ومنطقه الملازمين وحيا بروف والمناطق التي
فيها الاذاعه والتلفزيون هذا الجسر من
الكلى الجانبين تسيطر عليه قوات الدعم
السريع باعتبار ان الدائره الطبيه او
معسكر المظلات تاريخيا تتواجد فيه قوات
الدعم السريع وهي في منطقه بحري في
الاتجاه الثاني تتواجد فيه الاذاعه
والتلفزيون من خلال هذا الاتجاه تتواجد
قوات الدعم السريع هذا مثالا في مناطق
اخرى جسر الحلفايه وهي منطقه ايضا في بحر
ترتبط بامدرمان الشماليه في جانب بحري
هنالك امتداد لعدد من قوات الدعم السريع
في تلك المنطقه ودارت فيها اشتباكات اما
على الجانب الشمالي الاخر في مدينه ام
درمان فتتواجد القوات المسلحه بعدد من
القوات وتستطيع من خلال هذه المشاهدات ان
ترى عدد من الجسور الاخرى مثلا جسر
المنشيه تتواجد فيه قوات الدعم السريع وهو
الذي يربط ما بين منطقه الخرطوم وشرق
النيل وهذه منطقه ذات اهميه كبرى بالنسبه
لقوات الدعم السريع باعتبارها امتدت فيها
وانتشرت فيها وحكمت فيها السيطره ودارت
فيها معارك ما بين مضاداتها الارضيه
وطائرات الجو التابعه للجيش السوداني شكرا
جزيلا لك من الخرطومه الصحفي عمار ابو
شيبه
حرب الجنرلين التي اندلعت بسرعه بعد اخر
عشاء جمعهما لم تعطي عشرات الالاف فرصه
انتقائي مهربهم الالاف ممن يملكون سعر
التذكره والمقدره ب 400 دولار هرعوا على
متن حافلات متجهه لولايه كسلا في المنطقه
الشرقيه كسل الواقعه قرب الحدود مع
اريتريا هي تحوي معسكر ضخما للنازحين وتضم
جاليه اريتريه كبيره الامان التي برزت
امامهم وان لساعات سدت سريعا فخذلوا مرتين
اكثر من
3500 اريتري تم ترحيلهم لبلادهم قصرا وفق
صحيفه جاردن هؤلاء تم ابعادهم من المخيم
ارسلوا الى منطقه تسمى البوابه 13 قرب
الحدود تلقوا اوامر من قبل مسؤولي الامن
الارتري بالعبور الى اريتريا اذكروا ان
الاف الارتريين فروا سابقا من الجيش
الارتري الذي اجبرهم على الخدمه في اقليم
تيجرايف اثيوبيا وقدرت اعداد من استقروا
في السودان وقتها قبل اند لاع المعارك ب
126000 بينهم حوالي 75 الفا عالقين في
الخرطوم حيث يتركز القتال
[موسيقى]
مع اقتراب موعد الاقتراع تزايدت شكاوى
المعارضه التركيه بشان عداله ونزاهه عمليه
التصويت المعارضه تقول ان الانتخابات في
البلاد تجري على ارضيه غير متكافئه خاصه
في مجال استئثار الرئيس التركي بالاعلام
المحلي مزاعم غالبا ما يدعمها المراقبون
الدوليون وينفيها اردوغان وحسبه
[موسيقى]
رجب طيب اردوغان وحزبه امام امتحان جديد
واقوى تحد منذ عشرين عام على راس السلطه
البلاد على اعتاب انتخابات رئاسيه
وبرلمانيه غير مسبوقه الانتخابات تاتي في
ظل تزايد الشكاوى بشان عداله ونزاهه عمليه
التصويت المعارضه تقول ان الانتخابات
لطالما جرت على ارضيه غير متكافئه مزاعم
غالبا ما يدعمها المراقبون الدوليون ابرز
الامثله التي تطرحها المعارضه التركيه
التغطيه الاعلاميه التي يتمتع بها اردوغان
واستخدام موارد الدوله اثناء الحملات
الانتخابيه والتفسير المشكوك فيه لقانون
الانتخابات فحوالي 90% من وسائل الاعلام
التركيه تتركز في ايدي الحكومه وداعمها
وفق منظمه مراسلون بلا حدود ما يضمن وقتا
اطول من البث لصالح الرئيس فخلال شهر
ابريل الماضي حصل اردوغان على ما يقرب من
33 من البث على محطه التلفزيون التركيه
الرسميه في المقابل حصل خصمه الرئاسي كمال
كيتشدار اوغلو على 32 دقيقه فقط
حزب الشعب الجمهوري المعارض الابرز رفع
دعوى قضائيه الشهر الماضي ضد محطه تي ار
تي الرسميه لفشلها في عرض فيديو حملته
من جهته اكد حزب العداله والتنميه بقياده
اردوغان انه ملتزم باجراء انتخابات حره
ونزيهه تحترم اراده الشعب اردوغان ما فتى
ينوه بدمقراطيه التجربه التركيه اذ يسعى
للاحتفاظ بالسلطه ومواصله قياده البلاد
رغم الانتقادات اللاذعه التي يواجهها في
ظل ازمه اقتصاديه غير مسبوقه فضلا عن اثار
الزلزال الاخير بلال البجدين العربيه
الانتخابات الاهم في تاريخ تركيا الحديث
لكل الاطراف الائتلاف الحاكم وزعيمه رجب
طيب اردوغان وللمعارضه في مختلف في
تياراتها لاسيما تحالف الامه في هذه
الفقره نستعرض واياكم اهم التحالفات في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه القادمه اولا
تحالف الشعب او الجمهور يضم حزب العداله
والتنميه بزعامه اردوغان حزب الحركه
القوميه وحسب الاتحاد الكبير وجميع هذه
الاحزاب تنتمي الى تيار اليمين ويمين
الوسط اتفقت هذه الاحزاب منذ البدايه على
شخص اردوغان كمرشح مشترك ولم تشهد حتى
الان اي صراعات او اختلافات فيما بينهم
انضم الى هذا التحالف حزب الدعوه الحره
الاسلامي وهو حزب كردي اسلامي يسمى
اختصارا هدى بار ثم انضم للتحالف حزب
اليسار الاخضر الذي اسسه رئيس وزراء تركيا
الاسبق بولند اجاويد ايضا اعلن حزب رفاعي
الجديد الذي اسسه فاتح اربكان نجل نجم
الدين اربكان مؤسس الاحزاب الاسلاميه في
تركيا اعلن انضمامه لتحالف الشعب ما يعني
انه سيصحف فئه المحافظين لدعم اردوغان
جمهور الاشكال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نذهب معكم الى التحالف الثاني وهو تحالف
الامه المعارض يضم حزب الشعب الجمهوري
اليسار العلماني بزعامه كمال كلتش دار
اوغلو المرشح المشترك للتحالف وحزب الخير
اليمين القومي المتشدد وحزب السعاده
الاسلامي المحافظ والحزب الديمقراطي
القومي اليمين المحافظ وحزب الديمقراطيه
والتقدم وحزب المستقبل بزعامه احمد داوود
اوغلو يعتبر تحالف الامه اكبر تحالف معارض
في تركيا واختار كل تشتار اوغلو مرشحا
مشتركا وذلك بعد خلافات عميقه ما زاد من
قوه التحالف اعلان تحالف العمل والحريه
عدم اختيار مرشح خاص بالرئاسه ودعمه لكل
تشتار اوغلو في الانتخابات الرئاسيه وذلك
منعا لتشطيط اصوات المعارضه
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى اسطنبول ومعنا من هناك زاهد رئيس
تحرير تركيا اهلا بك سيد زاهد معنا في
التاسعه هذا المساء على العربيه هل يعول
على نتائج استطلاعات الانتخابات التركيه
كانتائج تحاكي الواقع ام انها ادوات
تستخدمها الاحزاب للتاثير على الناخبين
يعني ربما كان في هذا الكلام في السابق
بمعنى اننا قبل ان نتحدث عن التسييس الذي
تم ممارسته خلال السنوات الماضيه يمكن كان
هناك
نسبيا تعويل على استطلاعات الراي لكن بشكل
عام حقيقه في الاونه الاخيره كلنا نعلم ان
شركات استطلاعات الراي لا تظهر غالبيه
النتائج بالقدر الصحيح وعندما نتحدث عن
عينات تؤخذ عبر في الغالب عبر الاتصال
الهاتفي ربما يمكن الطعن في موثوقيتها
شخصيا انا لا اعول كثيرا على استطلاعات
الراي لكن اعول كثيرا على التقارير التي
تبعث توصلها ربما السفرات الاجنبيه الى
دوالها وربما يمكن القول ان احتماليه
خساره اردوغان اصبح واقعه حال في الكثير
من التقارير كاحتماليه قويه في العديد من
التقارير التي رفعتها العديد من السفارات
الاجنبيه والاوروبيه الى دولها خلال الشهر
الماضي وبالتالي اعتقد ان هناك تغيرا
محتملا بعد خمسه ايام سيحصل في الساحه
السياسيه التركيه استاذ زاهد هل تقوم فعلا
المعارضه بالدفع لشركات خاصه تمولها
وتدعمها من اجل التاثير على نتائج
استطلاعات الراي وبالتالي تاثير على عقليه
النخب التركي
يعني يمكن القول ان الكثير من شركات
استطلاعات الراي تاخذ الاموال من الطرفين
من المعارضه من جهه وهناك شركات معروفه
تعمل لصالح المعارضه ولا تعلن بطبيعه
الحال اي نتائج
فيما لا يريده دعني اقول المشتري وهي
المعارضه والعكس صحيح ايضا بالنسبه للحزب
الحاكم يعني نفس الامر يمارسه الحزب
الحاكم فلا يوجد هناك اي استطلاع للراي من
الشركات المواليه للحزب الحاكم سيظهر
تقدما للمعارضه في اي مكان علما اننا
عندما ننظر
بتجرد ان النقل مقارنه مع الارقام السابقه
التي حصدها حزب العداله والتنميه في 20
سنه في العديد من المناطق وضمن انتخابات
او قانون الانتخاب الجديد يمكننا ان نجزم
يقينا من الان ان المعارضه ستكون لديها
الاغلبيه البرلمانيه بسبب القانون الجديد
ابتداء وانتهاء والذي حزب العداله
والتنميه بشكل منفرد عن شريكه حزب الحركه
القوميه لو كان هناك تحالف حقيقي في تحالف
الجمهور بمعنى انها لو كانت تتوافر على
قوائم موحده لكان وحافظوا على الاغلبيه
البرلمانيه اما وقد افترق اعتقد ان الكفه
ستكون للمعارضه ابتداء في داخل البرلمان
ولا شك ان الحزم الاساسي هو انتخابات
الرئاسه تركيا
استخدمت المعارضه اللاجئين السوريين كورقه
ضد الحكومه خلال العقد الماضي ويعتبر
العلمانيون الاتراك في مقدمه داعين لترحيل
السوريين حيث ركزت المعارضه خطابها
بالكامل على الطرد السوريين واعادتهم خلال
سنتين الى بلادهم
عند تصويرها اي تقرير عن اللاجئين
السوريين في اسطنبول يكون حي الفاتح
وجهتنا الرئيسيه لماذا هذا الحي على وجه
التحديد لان عشرات بل مئات المحال
والمطاعم والشركات السوريه اختار اصحابها
الانطلاق من هذا الحي التاريخي الذي يعتبر
الاكثر استقطابا للاجئين
اذا القسم الاكبر من النشاط التجاري
والاقتصادي للاجئين السوريين يتركز في حي
الفاتح وهذا يعني بالضروره عماله سوريه
كبيره تعمل هنا كعماد الذي يعمل في احد
محل الحلويات وعماد كغيره من اللاجئين
يخشى نتائج الانتخابات القادمه يعني هو
بس الفكره انه ما نجح الرئيس اردوغان يعني
في
تخوفها لبعدين وين راح نروح بس ان شاء
الله ما بصير غير خير استخدمت المعارضه
اللاجئين السوريين كورقه ضد الحكومه خلال
العقد الماضي من خلال تحميلهم مسؤوليه
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه السيئه الانتقادات
تجاه اللاجئين تصاعدت بشكل كبير خلال
العامين الماضيين وقاد هذه الحمله على وجه
التحديد السياسي المتطرف المعادي للاجئين
اوميت اوز داغ
السوريون سنعيدهم
الى والاشياء الاخرى لا تهمك انت لست
مواطنا تركيا سنعيدك الى بلدك
مرشح المعارضه للرئاسه كمالك الجدار اوغلو
تعهد مرارا باعاده اللاجئين اذا وصل
للرئاسه التخوفات موجوده السبب التخوفات
حقيقه صادره من وين صادرا من استخدام
الاحزاب في تركيا لهذه الورقه من اجل
الانتخابات دائما التوجه لورقه اللاجئين
واستخدامها بطرق واساليب تعتبر لانك سوري
مستفزه وتعتبر مخيفه نوعا ما لماذا نحن
الحلقه الاضعف في النهايه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان تعهد كذلك باعاده اللاجئين الى
مناطق امنه شمالي سوريا مراقبون ارجعوا
موقف اردوغان لتنامي حاله شعبيه تريد حل
مشكله اللاجئين واعادتهم وبالتالي اراد
الرئيس سحب هذه الورقه من معارضيه
وفق القانون الرئيس هو من يقرر استقبال
موجات كبيره من مواطني دوله اخرى يتعرضون
للاضطهاد وفي ذات الوقت بقرار اداري من
الرئيس يمكن ان تتم اعادتهم لكن بشرط ضمان
شروط الحياه الانسانيه لهم في بلادهم
بالمحصله وكما في كل انتخابات تشهدها
البلاد حاله الخوف والقلق لدى اللاجئين
تبلغ اعلى مستوياتها قبل الانتخابات بايام
فحملات الوعيد والتهديد الصادره من
المنابر السياسيه تفوق بكثير بعض
التطمينات التي تاتي على خجل من هنا وهناك
زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
التاسعه هذا المساء مستمر ونتابع في سياق
ولكن بعد قليل
مهرجان وافلام السعوديه يحتفي بفيلم قصه
ملك الصحافه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا في التاسعه هذا المساء
وفيها ايضا نقلت رويترز عن مصادر
استخباراتيه اردنيه ودبلوماسيه غربيه
قولها ان الاردن نفذ غارتين على موقعين
المخدرات جنوبي سوريا وقالت رويترز ان
الغاره الاولى
استهدفتاجون في درعا والغاره الثانيه قتلت
المطلوبه الاول بتهريب المخدرات عند
الاردن مرعي الرمثان بمنزل الشرقي سويداء
وهو المسؤول عن عمليات التهريب ونقل
المخدرات من جنوب لبنان الى الاردن كما
قالت رويترز نقلا عن مصادر الاستخباراتيه
ودبلوماسيه ان مرعي الرمثا على علاقه
وثيقه بمليشيا حزب الله
وزير الخارجيه الاردنيه ايمن الصفدي قال
انه عندما يتخذ الاردن اي خطوه تتعلق
بتهديد امنه سيعلن عنها في الوقت المناسب
جاء ذلك ردا على الانباء التي تحدثت عن
استهداف سلاح الجو الاردني لتاجر مخدرات
في الجنوب السوري ما ادى لمقتله اكد صفد
ان الاردن اتفق مع سوريا على تشكيل فريق
امنيا سياسي لمواجهه خطر المخدرات
عندما نتخذ اي خطوه
لحمايه امننا الوطني ومواجهتي اي تهديد له
سنعلنها في وقتها المناسب بالنسبه لقضيه
المخدرات كما اكدنا سابقا هو هي تهديد
كبير للمملكه وللمنطقه وللعالم ايضا في
ضوء تصاعد عمليات تهريب المخدرات تذكرين
اننا في اجتماع عمان اشرنا الى هذا
اتفقنا مع اخوتنا في الحكومه السوريه
باننا سنشكل فريقا سياسيا
امنيا مشتركا لمواجهه هذا الخطر
الانتهاء منه بشكل كامل مستمرون في العمل
من اجل انشاء تلك اللجنه وساتصل بمعالي
وزير الخارجيه السوريه قريبا لنبحث كيف
نترجم هذا الاتفاق الى اليه عمل واضحه
تساعدنا على مواجهه هذا الخطر وتحدو منه
وعلى اتصال وقنواتنا مفتوحه مع الحكومه
السوريه
[موسيقى]
تزايد النفوذ الروسي في القاره السمراء
بات هاجسا يقلق الغرب وتحديدا رئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن حيث كشف تقرير عن صحيفه
بوليتيكو عن الاستراتيجيه الجديده للرئيس
الامريكي والتي سيسعى من خلالها لمواجهه
مجموعه فاقنر المنطقه
صراع النفوذ في منطقه الساحل الافريقي
متوسط بين واشنطن وموسكو التي تعمل على
توسيع وجودها كقوه لا يمكن احتوائها في
القاره السمراء جهود كبيره يتم بذلها من
طرف مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه في المنطقه
هدفها التمدد في البلدان الافريقيه
لمنافسه الغرب تحديدا واشنطن التي تسعى هي
الاخرى لضرب شبكات فاجنر العسكريه
ومصالحها الاقتصاديه فتحركات فاجنر باتت
مصدر قلق كبير بالنسبه للرئيس بايدن الذي
كشف عن استراتيجيه جديده تناولها تقرير
صادر عن صحيفه بوليتيكو يسعى من خلالها
لكبح المساعي الروسيه في المنطقه من خلال
تبادل المعلومات الاستخباراتيه الامريكيه
الحساسه المتعلقه بفاجنر مع الحلفاء في
افريقيا
واقناعهم بتجنب عقد شركات مع هذه المجموعه
بحسب الصحيفه هذا التكتيك يخدم الوظيفه
المزدوجه المتمثله في تنبيه الحلفاء
بالتهديدات واخطار الخصوم بان واشنطن على
درايه بتحركاتهم حيث تم الكشف عن معلومات
استخباراتيه تتعلق بخطه فاجنر لاغتيال
رئيس تشاد ومحاولتها الوصول الى مواقع
استخراج الموارد الطبيعيه والسيطره عليها
وغير بعيد عن ذلك عرضت واشنطن على جمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى تدريب جيشها مقابل طرد
قوات فاجنر وفق مقال لصحيفه لوموندا
الفرنسيه وذلك بعد ان تزايد النفوذ الروسي
في كل من السودان وليبيا وزيمبابوي
وبوركينا فاسو وتشاد والنيجر وموزمبيق
وجمهوريه الكونغو الديمقراطيه شبكه فاجنر
التي تسعى لابرام اتفاقيات دفاعيه وامنيه
من بوابه تقديم الدعم لدول افريقيا
تخفي وراء تحركاتها اطمع موسكو التي ترغب
في جعل روسيا احد المشاركين الاقوياء في
القاره
نشرت العائله الملكيه البريطانيه صور
رسميا لحفل تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث
متابعه
[موسيقى]
انتخابات بلديه تتويج واحتفالات تركت
المملكه المتحده في غرفه انتظار فما وراء
الاستمراريه المطليه بالذهب لاحتفالات
التتويج ادله عده تؤشر استعداد كلا من
بريطانيا وعائلتها المالكه لعصر جديد رغم
ان تغيير غير مضمون او حتى واضح الا انا
بريطانيا تقف على اعتاب التغيير في كل من
السياسه والنظام الملكي وفقا لصحيفه
نيويورك
ادى الى قلب الصفحه بشكل نهائي على حكم
والدته الذي دام سبعين عاما ووضع النظام
الملكي في خانه المستقبل غير مؤكد مع
تراجع نسبه المؤيدين الاستمراريات النظام
الملكي كما ان الهزيمه المؤلمه للمحافظين
في انتخابات رؤساء البلديات تشير الىنا
الحزب الحاكم في بريطانيا يمكن ان يخرج من
السلطه في الانتخابات العامه وبعد ثلاث
سنوات من خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد
الاوروبي وتسعه اشهر من وفاه ملكتهم لا
تزال البلاد تتلم طريقها للحصول على هويه
[موسيقى]
شاهد مهرجان وافلام السعوديه العرضه الاول
للفيلم الوثائقي قصه ملك الصحافه والذي
يتناول سيره الراحل تركي سديري والذي اطلق
عليه الملك الراحل عبد الله بن عبد العزيز
لقب ملك الصحافه
[موسيقى]
حضور كبير شهده العرض الاول للفيلم
الوثائقي قصه ملك الصحافه ضمن مهرجان
افلام السعوديه الفيلم وثق مسيره الصحفيه
السعودي الشهير تركي السديري الذي تراس
صحيفه الرياض لاكثر من اربعه عقود ولدت
فكره الفيلم الاستاذ التركي
اولا من شخص يعني صانع فيلم هو في الاساس
من مدرسه صحيفه الرياض التي كان يراسل
ديري حينما تفرقت يعني للعمل في السينما
كان من اول المشاريع اللي فكرت فيها هو
يعني ان نصنع فيلم يوثق سيره ملك الصحافه
الاستاذ تركي الفيلم هو في يمشي في خط
زمني واحد يعني لينير اوكي يتحدث من
بدايات
ولاده يعني من بدايه ولادته الى مراحل
المرء
الصحافه الرياضيه الى الصحافه الى الكتابه
الى مراحل يعني بيمر في مراحل وايضا
تحريات الوثائقيه تناول جوانب لاول مره
يسلط الضوء عليها في حياه الراحل تركي
السديري كالازمه الصحيه الذهنيه التي تعرض
لها اواخر حياته طبعا الفيلم بوضح لك اياه
ويقدم لا يقدم وجهه نظر فيه ويقدم حقائق
لكل الحق يتوجهه نظر في الراحه الله يرحمه
كما يشاء لكن الفيلم يعطيك حقيقه ولا
يعطيك وجهه نظر فيه ويعطيك معلومات مرت في
بدايه قبل صحية تحدياته في بدايه عمل
الصحفي في وسط عمله ثم النهايات ورحيله
تفاعل كبير لقاه فيلم قصه ملك الصحافه من
حضور مهرجان افلام السعوديه الذين اكدوا
ان شخصيه الراحل تركي الصديري تستحق مثل
هذا التقدير الفيلم جيد جدا يعني من ناحيه
المهنيه من ناحيه الموثوقيه من ناحيه
الاخراج الاض
واء اعتقد انه متكامل كان في خلق للازمه
خلق
لعلاقه تركي سديري مع الصحافه الورقيه خلق
لعلاقه مع الديجيتال ميديا خلق لحاله
مرضيه
اليوم فقط عرفها الجمهور يعني عبد الرحمن
العصيمي من الظهران العربيه
باندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا اختارت الصين
موقفا لا يصفها اي طرف بالحيادي رفض الدعم
روسيا بالسلاح حول صفات وراء العقوبات
الغربيه موقف اذا رمادي لم يمنع الشركات
الصينيه من استغلال الفراغ الذي تركته
الشركات الغربيه في روسيا وهو ما ميع
مفعول العقوبات الغربيه قبل ان تتحرك
واشنطن وتضغط املا في تغيير المعادله
الصينيه الروسيه
عقوبات لا تحصى وحصار اقتصادي لم يخطر على
بالي اكثر الروس تشاؤما
ووراء كل حزمه عقوبات اوروبيه تضحيه جديده
الا ان المنطقه الرماديه التي اختارتها
الصين جعلت من العقوبات مجرد خطط لا تمثل
الواقع
بمرور اشهر الحرب حل الواقع مكان التفاؤل
اذ لم تنفذ صواريخ روسيا بل بالعكس تخطت
صناعتها ازمه الرقائق واشباه الموصلات ولم
يبقى امام النيتو الا الحل الاخير
تجفيف المنبع ومعاقبه الشركات الصينيه
الثقه بين الاتحاد الاوروبي والصين ستنهار
اذا فرضت بروكس العقوبات على شركات صينيه
بزعم انها تساعد روسيا اوروبا قد تدخل
حربا امريكيه بالوكاله وتضع على المحك
علاقتها باكبر شركائها الاقتصاديين تقول
لغه تهديد واضحه تزامنت مع سياسه اليد
الممدوده التي رفعها وزير الخارجيه الصيني
الذي يبدا جولته الاوروبيه من باريس و
برلين وهما اكثر الدول اعتدالا في
العلاقات مع بلاده
العقوبات لا تزال حبيسه المسوده الا ان
استهداف سبعا من شركات التكنولوجيا الابرز
قد يفتح الباب للمزيد من العقوبات
والعقوبات المضاده في الوقت الذي تستفيد
الصين من تداعيات الحرب بفاعليه
يبدو ان الخطوات الامريكيه كانت اسرع من
ماكرون الذي عاد من الصين وهو يتلو عبارات
الاستقلاليه الاوروبيه ما يفتح الباب امام
انقسام اوروبيين حول جدول دخول صراع مع
الصين خدمه للاستراتيجيه الامريكيه دليل
اخر واشنطن لم تنجح في فرض العقوبات على
الصين عبر مجموعه السبع وتجد صعوبه مماثله
في فرض حظر تجاري كامل على روسيا بعد ان
فشلت قبلها في اقناع بالمفهوم الغربي
للحياد وهي التي منحت لشركاتها حريه
التعامل مع من تريد مقابل حصولها على
الكثير من النفط والغاز
المقومين باليوان
[موسيقى]
في نهايه التاسع هذا المساء لم يبقى لا
نذكر بالعناوين
عشيه الاحتفال بعيد النصر موسكو تكثف
غاراتيه على كييف والنيتو يرفع حاله
التاهب
عوده قويه للشبكات في الخرطوم واندرمان
وحرب السيطره على الجسور مستمره
[موسيقى]
باسم الشعب والامه حملات والمرشحه للرئاسه
التركيه تحاول استقطاب الاتراك بشعارات
الوطنيه
بالنسبه لقضيه المخدرات كما اكدنا سابقا
هو هي تهديد كبير للمملكه وللمنطقه
وللعالم ايضا
استهدف موقعين المخدرات بجنوب سوريا وقتل
المطلوب الاول
التاسعه هذا المساء انتهت ولكن اخبارنا
بالتاكيد مستمره بعد قليل نشرت 360 وساعه
اخباريه مختلفه مع كراويه
سنتحدث اليوم طبعا عن ملف الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه وتحديدا المخاوف من
حمله او ضربه عسكريه تحديدا باحتفالات يوم
النصر وايضا جديد المفاوضات في الملف
السوداني اليك شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات